born in Brooklyn in 1935 and began his
career as a reporter in 1960 at the New
York Post over the next four decades he
would cover New York City for the Daily
News New York Newsday New York New York
Times Magazine and The New Yorker Pete
Hamels new memoir of Manhattan is called
downtown he spoke about it recently at
the Brooklyn Public Library for about an
hour 15 minutes in going through this
book again I realized that this book is
part memoir part elegy it's the
historical social cultural architectural
physical geographical and commercial
story of Manhattan and as much as
anything it's about the creation of New
York and the formation of its character
and own this little package how many of
you have read the book that's great so
later when we take questions we'll have
people who will really get into the
nitty gritty so far this series has
limited itself to writers who live in
Brooklyn although many of them have come
here from elsewhere this is the I think
the first time we have had somebody who
is from Brooklyn but who now lives
elsewhere and has written about
elsewhere do you do you still think of
yourself as a Brooklynite oh how could I
not
I think the particularly the thing about
Brooklyn is that if you're if you have
been a child here there's something
about it that gets into you that you
carry around for life I'm not sure what
it is I mean walking up the stairs in
the library I was six years old in 1941
when the Dodgers won the pennant and
they weren't finished with this building
yet but right outside on those steps
there must have been 2,000 of us
gathered there to watch the look at the
motorcade on the come-up Eastern Parkway
a Eastern Parkway and I I carry that
around with me forever
I think the light is part of it I think
the presence of the park that there was
a kind of lyrical center of Brooklyn
that was wild or in a weird way the way
the design was then Central Park Central
Park you can't no matter where you stand
is the apartment house is somewhere over
here you can go and disappear into it
and become bomba the jungle boy over
there up in the Quaker Cemetery or these
days become Montgomery Clift up in the
Quaker Cemetery and I think that to have
those in a city is so unusual to have
something man had never had a beach you
know to have a beach in your own borough
it just never was there I think all
those things get into you early and and
you judge other cities through them
Manhattan to me was always a suburb of
Brooklyn
would you set eyes what it was ours we
said yeah it was ours I when you move
there he said we're not in Kansas any
yeah wouldn't had never having been in
Kansas at the time I moved to to
Manhattan I the I tell in the beginning
of this book my mother who was an
immigrant from Northern Ireland as was
my father they met here
they met at a place that's still here
the Webster Hall over on just below 14th
Street he couldn't play with us
as kids he had one leg he lost a leg
playing soccer in the immigrant leagues
which were all over New York in those
days there will be leagues with an Irish
team and a Jewish team and a German team
and he got kicked it was his bad luck
that had happened before there was
sulfur drugs of penicillin gangrene set
in boom so he couldn't do that but she
loved walking with us because it was the
depression I was born in 1935 and you
did whatever you could to entertain your
kids as long as it didn't cost money so
walking was the great enterprise and I
the book opens more or less because we
lived in a place where we couldn't see
we lived on 14th Street not far from
here 471 14th Street between eighth
Avenue in the park and you could not see
the skyline from there later when we
moved to seventh Avenue we could see it
and the harbor at the Harbor before the
Verrazano we could see everything from
7th Avenue but not that and that's
before it became fashionable Park Slope
that will yeah in those days if you
crossed ninth Street you were going into
some really scary place where we live
yeah we
we because the Ansonia Clock Factory was
a factory then you know it's where my
father worked there was a globe lighting
company that's the most expensive and
Aladdin carpet cleaning a carpet place
and national silver that made the worst
silverware in the world and we're proud
of it all had like yellow plastic
handles you know but anyway she would
take us on these walks and the one I
start the book with is about seeing the
skyline for the first time and three or
four months before that at the Sanders
breakdown Iran on Bartel pritchard
square she had taken me to see The
Wizard of Oz and I didn't remember
anything about it except skipping home
with her I was five and singing because
because because because because which
was it became a kind of slogan for
Brooklyn and and then it was really the
spring after that that she took us down
to see the bridge and as she walk the
Sun in the morning the Sun is at your
back because as we all know the Sun
rises in Prospect Park and sets as so
many lives do in New Jersey
and so we came up out of it and there
was the skyline just gilded with sun
like gold in the morning and she told me
this later I remembered the image but
not the words but she said that I just
said wow what is it and she said you've
seen it before
it's Oz and so it was and so the book
became what I learned in Oz I guess
that's a difference in our experience
because I grew up in Williamsburg and
crossing the Williamsburg Bridge you see
the Lower East Side it doesn't look like
oz or Ozzie and Harriet for that matter
what are you gonna read for us I thought
I'd read the opening of the book and
some a little part from the end if that
is of course it's that's okay
any objections this is a book about my
home city I was born in the immense and
beautiful segment of it called Brooklyn
but I've lived and worked for much of my
life in its center the long skinny
Island called Manhattan I live here
still with any luck at all I will die
here I have the native sons irrational
love of the place and often think of
William Faulkner's remark about his
native Mississippi and how he loved it
in spite of not because New York is a
city of daily irritations occasional
horrors hourly tests of will and even
courage and huge dollops of pure beauty
for any native the homeplace is infused
with a mixture of memory myth lore and
history bound together in an erratic
subjective way that's it's true of the
natives of New York as of the natives of
Oxford Mississippi that mysterious
mixture is why so much of this portrait
is personal past and present emerged in
its pages as they are in my
consciousness but something else is in
the mix - something magical and certain
moments of magic are always present
tense in my earliest memory I am five
years old coming home from the Sanders
Theatre of Brooklyn I am with my mother
and we have just seen The Wizard of Oz
the year is 1940 in the safe darkness of
the movie house I've seen Emerald
castles and a lion that talked in a road
made of glistening yellow bricks but in
memory all of that is a blur in memory
my mother takes my hand and the two of
us are skipping all the way home singing
because because because because because
on this wonderful evening my mother
still has brown hair she is laughing and
exuberant clearly made happy by going to
a movie with her oldest son I remember
nothing else except the word because
later I will learn that the woman I call
mom is actually and Evelyn Hamel an
immigrant from the hard dark city of
Belfast in Northern Ireland she arrives
in New York with perfect Irish timing on
the day the stock market crashed in 1929
she was then 19 the calamity of the
Great Depression did not dismay her she
went immediately to work for a rich
Manhattan family as a domestic servant
glad of the work joyous about being
again in the city of New York in all the
years that followed in the life of and
Evelyn that City would always be a
wonderland why because above all because
her journey in 1929 was and Evelyn's
second migration to a place that would
be her home until her death at 87 on
these streets she had once been five - I
would learn that in New York many
stories begin somewhere else
for people who become center fielders
and for those who start as domestics her
father was named Peter Devlin who went
to C as a youth became an engineer
traveled as far away as Yokohama and
Rangoon worked for years as an expert in
refrigeration for the Great White Fleet
in the banana trade with Central America
he was a belfast catholic and at sea he
was free of the accumulated bigotries
that went with the endless religious
quarrels that began in the Irish 17th
century when he married in his 30s and
soon fathered two children
Peter Devlin decided that it was time to
live again on land he had seen many
places in the world but he and his wife
chose New York the young family of four
settled in the Red Hook section of
Brooklyn in the parish of Mary's star of
the sea I always loved that name hard by
the harbor there we would work on the
ships of the Cunard Line but live on
land with his fight with his family the
devil and children the other was my
uncle Maurice would be raised in a city
when nobody cared about their religion
they would grow up in the greatest
metropolis in America where everything
was possible if only you worked above
all they would grow up free of the iron
certainties of the European past the
first requirement for creating an
American future then in 1916 while up
came the slaughters of the Great War
raised in distant Europe disaster struck
in Brooklyn
my grandfather Devlin fell from the deck
of a ship and was crushed between hull
and dock
my mother was then five and remembered
later the tumult and the tears in the
flattened Red Hook but few of the
details she did remember New York fading
into fog and the long voyage home across
the vast Atlantic her mother must have
known
German submarines were prowling the
approaches to Ireland and England but
she chose to risk any danger to get back
among her own people
one of the few consolations in any life
is a sense of the familiar with all of
its imperfections the widow and her
small children made it safely across the
Atlantic but that year Ireland was
seething with violence and sectarian
hatred at Easter there had been a
nationalist rising in Dublin against the
British rulers of Ireland with deaths
and executions for many people Irish
nationalism was exclusively Catholic it
wasn't and in the north all Catholics
were accused by some citizens of
stabbing England in the back weathermen
of Ulster were dying in vast numbers of
the psalm the theory wasn't accurate
many Catholics fought under the British
flag but the fury was real and so was
the fear somehow in the midst of so much
turbulence and fear young and devil and
managed to do what few women and almost
no Catholic women ever did in those
years she finished high school at same
year her mother a widowed mother died of
a stroke at age 47 and Anne Devlin now
an orphan decided that it was time to
return to the city she had last seen
slipping away into fog her brother
Maurice would stay in Belfast for
another 30 years but my mother would
sell the family piano by a steamship
ticket and go back to the place where
she had last seen her father long ago
when she was five then I tell the story
of my father which is a different story
he he finished the eighth grade and was
apprenticed out as a stonemason friend
you know which meant you worked for
nothing for four or five years and maybe
with some fortune you might get a job
and he was a wonderful soccer player by
all the accounts
of different people in 1963 I took him
back to Ireland and went up to the
neighborhood on top of the Falls Road
where he had grown up and went to see
his friend who was a novelist named
Michael McLafferty by then I was a
newspaper man and my father thought I
was it was the same as George Bernard
Shaw or something you know they took me
to see Mick Lambert he was a wonderful
writer and we sat around talking about
what it was like when they were young
guys playing football and then came
another guy very young about 23 24 who
was working in this school at the top of
the Falls Road and that was how I met
Seamus Heaney who later won the Nobel
Prize in poetry out of the impoverished
north so they my father obviously came
to America hoping that he would live
better every immigrant to us so it's
about optimism not about coming to the
place to stick out banks that was for
the big business guys you know and so he
came here and lost his life as I
mentioned earlier and and still had a
life I think of it all I think of him a
lot in the last couple of months
watching the the these sort of semi
feel-good pieces out of Walter Reed some
of the hospital's about these young
soldiers with their plastic and steel
legs and I want to say don't kid us all
together my father never played soccer
with one of his six sons he never played
baseball with in he never marched in a
st. Patrick's Day Parade he had an
artificial leg
and he had a life but at age 80 he still
hadn't gotten over it and I think it's
important that we
remember that what happens to kids when
they get limbs and legs blown off can be
permanent you hope for all of them they
have wonderful lives but maybe not my
mother and father got married in 1934 I
was born in 35 and he was a clerk at
Ralston switch was a grocery chain in
Brooklyn because they had hammered good
handwriting into him so he had very good
handwriting and they the offer the main
office was down by the Gowanus Canal on
9th Street kept walking on the left was
was brawl since and then and but he
didn't become a citizen for a long time
and I think it was the fear of the
humiliation of passing means I am
somehow you know not thinking he had he
had the most wonderful prose style it
was he would write to me when I was in
the Navy or something and say dear Pete
everything is copacetic with quotes
around you know we're having a wonderful
time with quotes around and a neat the
one I lost all those letters
unfortunately in a fire but he he didn't
quite know it all he didn't get as good
as Michael McClure Bertie at the at the
language of the oppressor but but he was
he was very good at it at loving it he
was a singer and this book is about what
happens when you live in a place and I
had the great good fortune to become a
reporter and that forced me to know it
in a way that I wouldn't have otherwise
I thought it you know I was 25 I thought
I know in New York I'm a New Yorker and
I'd go out to some murder somewhere
didn't know you I didn't know where I
was I'd say what happens here who are
these people how do they live
who the hell is major Deegan anyway you
know watching a major of you know and
that was the beginning of myself
education about New York and I think in
many ways any kind of an education
Leonard as you know from thousands of
guests that you've interview is an
exercise in being an autodidact you
teach yourself in the long run teachers
can give you shortcuts help you get
there make sure that that you don't
spend your life reading bomba the jungle
boy that you move on you know you get to
the Count of Monte Cristo and you get to
Treasure Island and although you know
the teachers can do wonderful things to
get including inspiring you to go on but
that in the end you teach yourself I
always think of George Bernard Shaw's
wonderful honor when she talks about
I've had a wonderful education except
for school you know I think that was
true but we went to the same school for
a little while Pratt and stood up then
was that a good experience for you
although it was great yeah I went to
Pratt I was trying to be an artist
because I had when I came back from
there maybe I tried to get into Columbia
and the guy it must have been the state
of my teeth he said have you ever
thought about being a dental technician
and I said okay I'll do something else
and I went to art school
then cuz I could draw a little bit but I
think you the newspaper business for me
it's not for everybody it's not for
every writer was my university my
graduate school everything because
varieties of human experience was this
ceaseless you began at the post yeah now
was the post most of us will remember
who took over the old journal American
building along the East River but where
were they before that they were at
seventy-five West Street
Azealia I still worry downtown yeah well
they were in downtown they were at 75
West Street the entrance was actually on
Washington Street and it was a wonderful
old building and run by then by Dorothea
Schiff who couldn't have been different
more different from Rupert Rupert
Murdoch you know the and it was a time
when it was the seventh of seven daily
newspapers in terms of circulation all
that so the staff was small and they
always took chances on people because
they didn't want to hire people
permanently in the summertime so I
started on John first you know they'd
have some tryout come in and Eleanor
Roosevelt would send like busted opera
singers down to tried there was one guy
like that he would write a little bit
start to sing you know
all the other descent Jeeps let's get
rid of this guy and they published her
her column by day was it Mike yeah
no was called dear reader or something
like that I can't remember any better I
remember it was the worst column in the
history of the world
you know except maybe given to that
but used to Nicholas Kristof people
would people would defy us to finish it
you know that you think you would win a
reward if you could read all the way to
the end it was only 540 words or
something but but she was a good
publisher in the sense that she had
courage she she'd let the paper really
fight Joe McCarthy at the peak of his
power not later we everybody could be
brave because he's already been yeah
beaten gets Wexler yeah and who actually
defended Wexler
so was it was a weird paper because I
the Dear Abby type column was written by
a German shrink I'm an illegitimate
psychiatrist for the name like
Frankenheimer's no rose franzblau
franzblau right because every night when
the column would come in changed look at
franzblau you'd hear people around the
city room you know and it would always
be my husband is 39 he's still wetting
the bed what should you mothers there
were but she did for idea dancers he's
only doing that yeah because he was
frightened by a horse when his mother
don't know
you know it was hilarious
well in the book well first what you say
that you didn't learn to drive until you
were in your mid-30s which is typical of
New York as some of us never really
learned to drive or in my case I learned
to drive around that time and nobody
will allow me to drive now then so you
take us on a kind of a walking tour but
this is the you try to keep it orderly
as you can but you wind have gone all
over the place which I guess is part of
the fun of walking through New York and
and part of the fun of being an
individual because in the end that's the
way you see the world it's very like
steinberg's famous photograph of
Manhattan where it's had its pointed
west but you see California's there's a
little sliver up here in the the
driveway Avenue is like the joy you have
been adding ya the cover of The New
Yorker yeah but I have your order and
there's a kind of a couple of bumps and
then it says California at the end and
then Pacific Ocean and and and I have a
very subjective view of it for example
the to me the failure theater on
Broadway at 94th Street I guess it was
yeah is downtown to me because I've in
my mind it's part of the the art the
eighth Street and the Waverly are all
mixed in together the same movies were
playing it was always Fellini Kurosawa
Bergman etc and they've I think they had
one print of each movie like a bicycle
they each and Rockefeller Center is
triumphantly midtown and its northern
frontier is 53rd Street but to meet PJ
Clark's on 55th Street it's downtown
because of the patina of time some of
the people in the place when I was going
there I think what born in the 19th
century and it had the same outer Ward
as cigarette machines for about 30 years
just said out of order and there was a
pack of old golds or something in there
that you couldn't get out so I love that
part of it also had the greatest urinals
in New York they used these giant blocks
of ice and the Farrell's on 9th Avenue
and 16th Street hadn't for one might
still had the same urinals and the
writer Joe clarity who lived right near
here once described them as looking like
stall showers for Toulouse Lautrec and
another like yesterday it was at moment
I see something loose like Joseph's I
imagine them you know in Farrell's or PJ
Clark's pulling that little handle so
it's it's very subjective in that sense
but my my basic point is that much of
what we call New York including Brooklyn
is the result of the 19th century with
one huge exception which is the legacy
of the Dutch but we could not have made
this thing work without the greatest
gift the Dutch gave us which was
tolerance and the Dutch were not gauzy
eyed liberal idealist they were
practical people and they knew that if
they were ever gonna make a place work
like the one they were putting together
in lower Manhattan that meant they
couldn't have people who will like them
the Netherlands was a prosperous country
one of the most prosperous in Europe and
one of the most tolerant it's why if you
look at Rembrandt just see so many
paintings of Jews you don't find them
anywhere else except in the Netherlands
because people were welcome it was a
practical intelligent way to run a
country and that's what they did here
they said
we can't get people to emigrate to this
godforsaken place from a rich country
people from rich countries have never
never in a emigrate they never leave
we're gonna get everybody else the
Huguenots people distressed people etc
and then there were the people they
brought which were African slaves and
they brought and that combination of the
Dutch who were much more intelligent
even about slavery than the British were
when they came in a lot of freed slaves
were reinstate abhrush after they took
the place at the point of a gun but they
became part of a basic thing of New York
and I try to be fair in this book to
what Washington Irving wonderfully
called the Knickerbockers and I think
often how Washington Irving woulda loved
meeting Patrick Ewing Latrell Sprewell
and all these later Knickerbocker not
the current era but not the current team
but the the those people to that
combination that was here before the
immigrants arrived what we think of as
the immigrants which was the Africans
who were born here the African America
first African Americans and the
Knickerbockers which was a melding of
the British and the Dutch were the with
the basic materials of the city and then
when the immigrants came in the time of
the 1840s in large numbers there was
something there our template had been
cut but you also say that they set the
tone in another way the first Dutch
colonial governor was the first of our
leaders to cook the books yeah and then
later British dog food building was
invented under the the second the second
governor we ever had and then the the
British governor of the area Lord
Cornbury well you know he was a
transvestite wasn't it he would he would
parade around the the ramparts of the
fort in a dress dressed as Queen Anne
and had his portrait painted that way
and they have it at the the portrait of
Lord Cornbury is I think at the
Historical Society but his position on
gay marriage was ambivalent so is mine
what I want is a constitutional
amendment get rid of the D H you know
something you know I agree not this
trivial stuff you the whole history is
kind of personalized here you go by
Trinity Church and you remember when you
were a messenger down there working in
the equitable building and that gives
you a chance to talk about yeah the
equitable building and that's really a
wonderful way to tell the story because
for native New Yorkers that's the way we
learn the city we didn't learn it from
some guidebook we learned it from the
first job that we had and the places
that our boss has sent us to when we
were messenger boys or girls or whatever
and you know where we got lost in the
subway or and found ourselves in a
strange neighborhood that's how we all
get much learn the city yeah and I think
it's a great way to learn it too because
it you can touch it you know it's not an
abstraction it's not trying to figure
out is it the tigris that's more
important though that you Fraidy you
know all that stuff they would load us
with when we weren't we weren't even
told anything about our own city to this
day it's not taught in my opinion well
enough it's in the city's not marked
Leonard you know there's no it's very
seldom that you pass a street and find
out that Herman Melville got born here
or or don't Capone so then you go to
London and they have these signs on
these buildings William Butler Yeats
lived here yeah 1912 to 1915 nothing
like that here and you wonder why you
know I mean look Webster Hall you
mentioned that on what is that East 11th
Street you there should be a sign that
says Pete Hamels parents met
at an Irish dance we don't have Irish
dances parents alas but that here but we
don't have it marked you know we don't
we don't know for example if you walk
down second Avenue where I used to live
at second Avenue nice turn now loved
walking down there because all the
ghosts of the Yiddish theater were there
you know and and I came out I wasn't I
couldn't read you there sure anything
but I came out of backwards from some
people who were still there they were
occupied that the theaters were all
occupied by off-broadway what became
off-broadway and some of the little
restaurants were there the jam spa and a
couple of appetizing stores as they call
them and then they were all gone because
there was nobody to replace the
generation just before the the arrival
of Hitler the second Avenue Yiddish
theater didn't came to an end because
Hitler killed all the people who could
speak Yiddish and you get a little bits
and pieces of it now outside the second
Avenue deli places like the oven door
for library there and there you know
Ethan when I was a kid there was still
some old Jews who would come in
Ukrainians and now it's mostly Latinos
and Chinese doing the same thing and
trying to learn enough English to get
paid trying to learn enough English to
be polite
and trying to learn enough English to
get the kids to live better lives and
they did and that's thrilling to me when
I walk into a place like the outdoor
fruits and and at the little Hospital
right next door to word on Second Avenue
and ninth Street that we have that kind
of continuity is the thing that we
should we should embrace and well that's
one of the themes to this book but
nostalgia I guess they're tied together
runs through it all in fact you actually
write about New York anthropomorphic lay
where you attributed nostalgia to the
whole city but in
it's you suggest that nostalgia is one
of the city's ruling passions along with
greed anger resistance to Authority and
is it because for immigrants nostalgia
is so key they have nostalgia for the
old country as you you said and then
they come here experience it at a
certain point and then watch it change
again Webster Hall now what did what do
they do rock music yeah yeah
there aren't any Irish dances in New
York not that I know of
you know them in fact the the Irish the
last Irish migration wave which was said
18 1970-1980 is reversed and there's
more net returned to Ireland than
arrivals from our this is more jealously
prosperity you know but you say because
the city changes so quickly every
generation watch it's its own past being
demolished yeah but I talk about what's
something that's obvious the velocity of
change and in my lifetime we learned how
to lose things we've learnt we lost that
it's filled we lost the Polo Grounds we
lost Penn Station you know and you say
how could this be done how could they
tear Penn Station down put on this
current version of Madison Square Garden
which looks like Minneapolis or
something you know
area code 800 and at the same time those
things led to gains I mean once they the
atrocity of destroying Penn Station took
place the Landmarks Preservation
movement really began in earnest and
saved a lot of things but why do you
think we're selective in it when people
you mentioned poll the grounds most
people don't they the Dodgers and the
Giants were equally loved and yet all
that anybody talks about is the Dodgers
maybe it's because Brooklyn is so
powerful Penn Station was lost but so is
the Metropolitan Opera House so we're a
lot of other wonderful buildings we tend
to pick one or two and maybe it's
because we really have
to accept as you say the permanence of
loss in the city that that's it's always
going to change so we pick a couple of
symbols and then yeah we let yeah I
think that's absolutely true
I think the Dodgers think cuz I will
often wondered why do they so many
people still hold the Dodgers as
something you put more important than
what happened to the Giants you know
there were just as many good players
just as really Mays I think the
difference was Robinson that when
Robinson came in 47 in April 15 1947 to
play at Evans field suddenly it became
more than a game it wasn't just baseball
and even we kids I was then 12 we
understood that somehow you know maybe
not at first because we it was it's hard
for kids to understand race under
certain circumstances they don't they're
not familiar it's not that they're
racist or not that they're not racist
they just that hasn't occurred to them
and the great migration from the south
of african-americans was just getting
underway in 1947 but it made rooting for
Brooklyn a kind of moral act and and we
didn't call it that either any more than
asking the first moral questions anybody
that I know asked any kid was after
seeing those movies of from
bergen-belsen and Buchenwald and right
after the war seeing them at the
prospect and seeing them at the Sanders
and saying how did this happen
who let this happen what is this
we didn't know we were kids we were ten
and they were the first we didn't think
this way but they were the first moral
questions we
and the second set of moral questions
were about Robinson and about race I
could get have a ask people go to fight
in a war and not let them play baseball
and what he did was it wasn't that he
integrated baseball he integrated the
stands and suddenly all the tribes of
Brooklyn were in the same place and
there were Dodgers fans in Minnesota and
yeah Wyoming and wherever there were
black people in this country you know it
didn't hurt that the Dodgers became a
much better team around that time
because of Robinson and a bunch of other
players as well but suddenly energized
Brooklyn baseball but what it did for
white kids is often overlooked you know
it's obvious that if you were an
african-american kid growing up in Selma
Alabama in 1948 you were from Brooklyn -
if you were growing up on 118 and Lenox
the year of Robinson you were from
Brooklyn - if you were some old guy that
fought in World War one and living in
New Orleans and your african-american
you're from Brooklyn - boundaries of
Brooklyn expanded unbelievably but we
have a short memory because the Yankees
were the last team to integrate in the
city and among the lasts in all the
baseball they really held out to the
bitter end
and yet I would say that the Yankees
enjoy an incredible african-american
following so people - yeah now they do
forgive and forget it provided the guys
can hit and run well Elston Howard was
the first Yankee black Yankee that's
pretty late and he came the year that
the Dodgers finally beat the Yankees
which was 50 years ago this year 9 1955
Elston Howard the Dodgers however was so
good that they had a guy on the World
Series roster who never got to throw a
ball named Sandy Koufax
he wasn't that good yet he made it to
the team this book is as much about
nostalgia for your past isn't it it came
of age at a wonderful time in New York
when Abstract Expressionism was suddenly
making New York the center of the art
world when the beats were all hanging
around here and I get the sense that you
actually mixed with some of them I know
I met Jack Kerouac once and it was kind
of like get away kid you're bothering me
but you were a little older so he wasn't
that articulate I don't know but it was
true you I went across the river with
two of my friends in 1957 all three of
us from Brooklyn I had just finished a
year in Mexico go to art school and we
were able to get an apartment for $65 a
month divided by three no and my friend
Ruben blades the Panamanian singer says
new york he said
this place has the craziest nostalgia it
has rent nostalgia it's a you know even
ancient rome didn't have that nostalgia
so so we were lucky because you could
you know you didn't pay all to spend a
lot of money on rent you didn't have it
anyway but you could go to the cedar
tavern on University Place the old one
not the one that's been there for 40
years and stand at the bar and put $2
down and last for a couple of hours and
talk to Franz Kline or Helen Frankenthal
or
a Pollock would come in incoherent once
around
Leroy Jones but Leroy Chiao very
powerful Rosenberg who was a great big
tall guy they would all come in that
place and you could just sit there as a
kid and listen you didn't have to ask
question you didn't and most of what
they were arguing about by the way was
why can't Brooklyn get a center fielder
yeah you know I mean so that feel aleph
yeah why can't they get what's the
matter with Billy Cox why did he leave
you know that no that's the kind of
arguments they were having because there
was no television set in the exceeded
time but and they had this place called
the club where you could go in once a
week to lectures about all kinds of
things mostly art but and you could
pretend to understand every word that
was uttered they usually didn't I got
the sense reading the book that what
seems permanent when we're 20 is often
gone by the time we're 30 maybe that's
life in general but in New York even
more so you go on vacation you come back
you say when did the Carvel close and
what is this you know there's a that's
what I mean by gap story here now the
velocity of change you know it's in the
creates this kind of very quick sense of
nostalgia and I don't mean
sentimentality sentimentality is a lie
it's a saying something about a world
that you didn't experience you know that
that you had no contact in some way with
and falsifying it's like it's the
ultimate sentimentality to have
nostalgia for the old days of the draft
riots you know well I wasn't that fun
throwing those bricks you can't have
that but this that exactly that change
lino that you're talking about is what
is part of it and the thing we we never
finished program
which is the presence of this in this
place of so many immigrants because no
matter what drove them out of the old
country they came when they were 11 or
12 most of them and they had a lead
behind a place maybe it oppressed them
religiously or politically maybe there
was famine maybe there was hunger
there's all the conventional reasons for
leaving but it was the place where they
were once 10 or 11 running in the fields
in the summertime barefoot it's still
happening but instead of coming to the
downtown area or Brooklyn they're going
to Queens it's just a different group of
immigrants but in the end is I assume
it's the same experience it's my mother
you know it's like a house that you're
right about here a lot of these things
remain the same even though they're
different you write about a Scottish
immigrant who started a newspaper on
very little $500 $500 and something at
that and some James Gordon Ben yes and
he he started I don't know if he started
it but he specialized at the Herald in
if it bleeds it leads and we complain
today about that sort of journalism well
there he was in what the 1830s or so
yeah doing scandals and doing muggings
and killings the same stuff that we have
today and he did it by accident you know
he didn't know there was a murder on the
downtown near where the Odeon restaurant
is downtown a woman named Helen Jewett
the prostitute was found hit with an axe
buy some dope and we're know off into
the night and Bennett walked in and
wrote down everything he saw what the
body looked like the blood on the floor
and then he notices in the bookcase
books books by Dickens bulwer-lytton
Coleridge Alexander Pope and a
photograph of Lord Byron over the
bookcase and he realizes this is not
your ordinary pasta too began to dig
into it his circulation went from a
thousand a day to thirty thousand once
he printed this sort of panting
description of the body it was it was
like softcore porn as many feminist
scholars have pointed out looking at it
since then but it changed the metrics
again for the newspapers before that
move newspapers were for the upper-class
businessman
they were gigantic like this you know
you needed a table to put them on and
they were about shipping news and
certainly political stuff from Europe
you know things that might affect
business and change Gordon Bennett in
the New York Herald decided New Yorkers
love this stuff and it's been part of
our newspapers ever since murder and a
good address however yeah and and all
the newspapers are at pretty much the
same address Park Row which is and all
of them now are kind of jnr I think
aren't they yeah yeah they The Times
couldn't afford it so they moved uptown
and actually did better because they
were the the poor kid on the block
Bennett did then it moved first he moved
right to Herald Square that's why it's
called Herald Square right outside
Macy's and because he convinced the
Tammany guys to let him call it Herald
Square Adolph Ochs when he moved the
Times up to what was then Longacre
square a hundred years ago last year he
insisted it be called Times Square and
they went along with it and there were
some people that one of my favorite
writers is he says long-dead aj Liebling
from The New Yorker who wrote about the
press and boxing and World War two and
all that and he called it Longacre
square to the end of his
he wasn't gonna give it to the times you
know no matter what one of the recurring
characters in the book is Stanford white
a great architect but I have a feeling
that he's as important because of the
scandalous way he died as for all of the
great buildings that he left me oh I
think now probably that's probably true
but I think he was the greatest New York
architect of the twenty of the 19th
century and into the beginning of the
20th century and his city is is one I
love more than the other I'm I don't
like most of the skyscrapers
I like the Woolworth Building and like
the Chrysler a few others Empire State
Building to me the only good two good
things about it one there was the scene
of the greatest New York love story ever
written came calm and it's got the best
view with the Chrysler Building
you know when you go up there you can
see the Chrysler Building but to trouble
with the with the skyscrapers you can't
see them okay we have two skylines and
you got to go to Jersey to see both of
them the downtown in the Midtown block
but I like the horizontal city the city
of Stanford wide the City of the Century
Club and the Metropolitan Museum and the
Frick places that you can take in just
standing there you can take it all in
and it has a human thing that you can
read in a way I love the Customs House
which is Cass Gilbert downtown he also
did the Woolworths and he did the
Woolworth Building and one other on the
other side of where the World Trade
Center was to get the name of it there
rehabbing it now
I like those buildings and I think we're
lucky that we still have them in this
city we don't lose but we did we lost
the World Trade Towers in a way that was
Morris was a typical of New York do you
describe George Washington top his horse
the buildings around him smoldering as
the defeated British Navy is retreating
and it turns out to be just a couple of
years
away from where the World Trade Center
buildings fell you know we used to
celebrated actually I love Washington in
a way he in in most ways he was he
didn't solve slavery and he was maybe
the only guy with enough clout to do it
but he Frieda slave buddy yeah he did
but he he had a certain pride that I
think it was necessary to put into the
country I don't mean just vanity well
though he had that too and on what
became known as evacuation day my friend
Clyde Haberman at the times always says
geez I hate that name it sounds like a
visit to a proctologist you know what is
this a priced evacuation there but it
was the biggest holiday because he
waited up by 3rd Avenue in the bower I
mean the Bowery and Canal Street until
the last British ship was boarded and
then they went down to take the city you
know he wouldn't go down he wasn't gonna
shake hands he wasn't going to embrace
the enemy
he waited the last guy got on that boat
he said let's go all these beat up
wounded amateur soldiers or went down
and it's one of it's one of my favorite
moments in New York history because the
good guys won you know they were not
perfect men and it's hard to imagine how
they didn't see that or see what was
coming as a result of it not just the
racism but the civil war and that that
was gonna hurt our country but look what
they went through and how they came out
at the end you know it's an amazing
moment for us I have lots of other
things I wanted to talk about the
creation of tap dancing and
stores and means as long as I don't have
to do it I can tell it but I know I I
think it's time to throw this open to
this wonderful audience here and they've
been sitting here patiently we have
questions right over there yes sir
there's somebody over there I saw had
yes was that linear terrific storyteller
when I was in the fire opal in the 60s I
used to listen to Jean Shepard and he
was a great storyteller too what did you
what do you make of his his work well I
thought it was great and then when I
could listen to it I listened to it more
at the end of the 50s than into the 60s
because once I started writing for a
living I couldn't listen to it it's like
a lot of radio you can't write and
listen to other guys words pounding it
he has like reading two books at the
same time but I thought he was he was
terrific and original that he made you
think of possibilities I don't mean for
yourself I mean that that there were
different ways to be talk-show host and
not different ways to be Americans and
it was a good time to be listening to
the radio but I didn't drive a car as
letter boy so I never heard Jean Shepard
in a car and he I was chasing around
town various other interests and and
didn't want to go home and listen to the
radio we used to say about guys who went
home without a woman that he went home
with the news and mirror you know the
two newspapers and but he also
encouraged as kind of an anarchistic
streak especially in teenagers which I
was when he was on the air he'd have you
put the radio out of your window and
he'd scream I hate all of you
you know and my mother
say what are you doing and then he had
everybody go to bookstores to buy a
non-existent book which he then had to
write because it was such a big hand for
it but my big problem with Jean Shepard
was he was a Chicagoan and really all of
his stories had to do with Chicago and I
wondered what the heck is this guy
talking about Chicago here in New York
as Greater Chicago is I would have
preferred a New Yorker going to Chicago
and talking about New York what do you
think yeah
which probably eventually happened they
I suspect I remember the the guys that I
remember most in the 50s or people like
Symphony said and Long John Nebel there
was another character he was always
talking about messages coming in fresh
from Mars or so on and that was as good
as some of the stuff I hear coming out
of the White House yes sir mr. Hammill
I'm raising two young kids here in
Brooklyn as your own children were
growing up the Brooklyn Dodgers were
gone the Brooklyn Eagle had folded the
jobs were gone from the Brooklyn Navy
Yard and the great suburban flight had
begun but you brought them back here in
part to raise them how do they feel
about Brooklyn today it's hard to put
words in their mouth but I think they
feel the same they feel the same emotion
which is a kind of nostalgia for being
young without with none of the details
that were part of my life you know I'm
sure they didn't read many comic books
they didn't the you know they went to
schools right around here but they
didn't they didn't have those ballparks
but remember that yeah one of the
reasons I'm against this Stadium on the
west side as these guys land on us when
we were in a worse trouble we were we
had been in for a long long time they
packed up and went to New Jersey like
every other Lannister in history and I
don't think we should be rewarding them
with anything I just want to add this
one point that I'm sure you've been back
to note that the sidewalk around Baro
Pritchard Circle across from the former
Sanders theater is paved with yellow
brick
I always know that but the prospect is a
c-town supermarket right it's still bad
because the prospect was even the great
theater yet I learned later about the
prospect that it was one of the places
where Alger Hiss went to meet Whittaker
Chambers in the days of great dark
conspiracies I don't know what they
ended up reporting back to the FBI or
the KGB but it must have been you know
well I think but something about the
unit my lriend I still at the C town
yeah we weren't selling pumpkins and now
you bunny your other books the snows of
August I found a lot of nostalgic
references to Park Slope and Suffolk
found a very but I was always curious is
what led you to bring a golem into
Brooklyn in 1989 I went to I had been a
Shabbos [ __ ] so I had had that part of
the book under control
and I always thought that was like an
amazing accomplishment you know I might
not I might want to hit a double and
ground out to the shortstop I might have
a you know wish I could get a 95 and
into a good high school and end up
blowing it but I was a Shabbos [ __ ] you
know and then then I learned later
explain that to some people yeah Shabbos
[ __ ] is a Christian who on the Sabbath
will come in and do certain tasks that
are thought of as work and therefore in
violation of the Sabbath and it wasn't a
lot of heavy lifting it was like working
for the borough president's office turn
on the lights but in 1989 I went to
Prague to cover the fall of communism
and it was the most one of the most
exhilarating stories I'd ever covered
because first it was a revolt led by a
right
by Bosch laughs Havel somebody from my
guilt and they did it with laughter they
just left these dopes out of power
without firing a pistol you know it was
the way people could do things if they
know the tanks are not coming around the
corner and Gorbachev made sure no tanks
and so but the the guys at Randall were
all hippies the revolution started
around two o'clock in the afternoon so I
had to do something in the mornings and
decided to go look to see where Kafka
lived because Kafka was on the the
Communist didn't like Kafka and so it
wasn't easy to get official stuff about
Kafka's Prague or anything so I had a
guide and he took me around and it led
me in a roundabout way because Kafka
lived in about six or seven places more
than I did in the period of time that he
was there and led me into the old Jewish
ghetto and Prague which was intact had
not been destroyed by Allied bombing or
by the Russians it was intact even the
Nazis had left him along they were gonna
build a museum of decadent art or
something out of it and they held on to
it and he showed me around and showed me
the cemetery and the altar synagogue on
and told me about rabbi hello and the
golem and I had never heard of it before
and then realized holy God this is where
Mary Shelley must have picked out of
this story I think she did and and said
she's I wish I had a golem when I was
about eleven like you're suggesting and
that was the beginning of the idea of
the knowledge what if I did it's a novel
that's about I I always try to describe
the theme as first to imagine and then
you live you know you have to be able to
imagine Captain Marvel and imagine
Jackie Robinson before you can see him
vision it's from the world of know
before television and if you want to
imagine a golem you can have them it's
somebody back there yes give me a book
called
Harlem the making of a ghetto wishing
effect is a history of New York City
because the African Americans who live
downtown Manhattan until they move
continuously Midtown Harlem and you know
it
describes not only the experiences of
African Americans but the experiences of
all citizens residents of the city at
that time the Irish when they came
across in the nineteenth century you
know and given the circumstances that
they came from and the fact that this
that book describes it they would they
were treated as badly as
african-americans at that time you know
it seems strange to me that you know a
natural alliance wasn't wasn't wasn't
forged and I wonder if you'd care to
comment on it well there's a very good
book called
how the Irish became white that tells
about not only that part that that
you're talking about because the
original Irish african-american grouping
was based on class not race you know you
could live wherever you could afford to
live so if you could afford $10 a month
you live there and your neighbors were
other people who were Ford to who could
afford that we didn't get ghettos racial
ghettos until much later the Harlem as a
black ghetto is a 20th century thing
happens after the turn of into the 20th
century and it created a certain amount
of power and protection for people who
felt endangered but also it created a
sense of isolation I think
within that ghetto we it's what's
interesting now but this migration is
just it's not arranging itself that way
The Times had a very good piece a couple
of weeks ago on a new report that shows
people from Bangladesh and Chinese
living in the same parts of Brooklyn or
Queens because they can afford it and so
that to me that's an advance I think
there was something work valuable and in
having a Harlem but there was a downside
to it too but Pete don't you think that
one of the differences is that the Irish
then started getting involved in
politics and they got into the police
force blacks couldn't and so so certain
immigrant groups would give an entree or
found ways to gain entree into the power
structure and others were denied it and
that's and so the Alliance didn't occur
because people were all turning a little
piece of the same pie and some people
figured out where we're allowed to get
more of a piece than others well I I
think all those things are true Leonard
and the Irish also had rioted and killed
a lot of people during the draft riots
and later on in the orange riots on
eighth Avenue in 23rd Street in 1870 and
1871 they had showed some of them I
don't mean all the Irish but some of
them showed that they were willing to
get violent in order to get entry into
this society and then by the end of for
example the great cartoonist Thomas Nast
who brought down boss tweed was a
virulent anti-irish anti-catholic
cartoonist
by the 1880 was unemployable by then the
Irish had the jobs had the had lawyers
had people who had been educated because
when they came when the Irish came in
1847 and eight and nine
most of them were illiterate 70% were
illiterate a hundred thousand of the
first wave couldn't speak English they
had come from these little godforsaken
towns in the West of Ireland to New York
without seeing Dublin they'd never seen
a city till they got here and so took a
while and once they started getting
educated and took over politics through
Tammany Hall through all these corrupt
bosses and everything they they found
their way into a more civilized life and
by then race had gotten worse because
the consequences of reconstruction were
now showing themselves in the north in
addition to the south and it took a lot
of more lot more people how to get hurt
before that began to fade away
one more question yeah we wait for the
microphone
okay Pete you mentioned in your book
that you heard the Clancy Brothers when
they were first starting out remember
Liam Clancy giving a talk at one some
years ago he said that when they first
started doing their music in New York
most of their fans were Jewish because
the Irish of that era couldn't
appreciate their music they wanted to
hear Irish eyes are smiling come back to
eret and they didn't understand this new
kind of Irish music did you find that
was true with your parents generation
that they couldn't make heads or tails
of the Clancy Brothers oh no no they
they because they knew some of the songs
that the clancy's had revived but they
knew Galway Bay and if you're Irish come
into the parlor no saw the Tin Pan Alley
Irish stuff most of which was written by
people who were not Irish I tell the
story of I'll take you home again
Kathleen in this book and it's written
by schoolteacher in Indiana who had
nothing to do with the Irish diaspora or
anything else there was a market for it
for that kind of me wasn't giving and
again it goes back to the persistence of
nostalgia among immigrants and the
longing for the old country the stuff
the Clancy Brothers brought was stuff
that was so old it was new you know it
was stuff people knew from long ago and
a day themselves when I first went to
Ireland they were and and Tom Clancy
tells the same story you go to a
dancehall I'd be playing moon over Miami
you know you say wait a minute this is
Dublin but moon over Miami maybe is what
they wanted to go and do you know or be
the planets or this were playing in the
lion's head which was your favorite
hanging and the white horse so Jessica
Lange was the waitress says yeah the
line said yeah that that place is
another one that closed it's gone oh
well gone with just just one more thing
because we are running out of time we
didn't get to the whole business of the
grid I I read a lot about the grid but I
didn't realize that two notable
yorkers were really opposed to and I'm
sure that meant a lot of others were
Clement Clarke Moore who until fairly
recently was credited with writing twas
the night before Christmas he was really
against it and then you say Henry genius
every James hated it the grid was
designed by a committee actually but it
was commissioned by DeWitt Clinton maybe
certainly one of the great politicians
of the 19th century to bring order to
Manhattan it was the plan from Manhattan
and they came up with again like the
Brooklyn borough president's office they
said why don't we have streets that go
east and west and avenues that go north
and south and that was the grid and it
made Manhattan an amazingly capable of
growth because the real estate guys
loved it it was standardized as
essentially above the village they they
looked at the village and said that's
why West 4th crosses West 10th you know
and so they started it just above then
just above the village and it created a
kind of psychological thing I think too
that we're we're sort of right-angled
people in Manhattan you know and even in
even in Brooklyn or Queens where the
whole boroughs are not there's no grid
for the whole boroughs but each
individual Hamlet has a kind of
structure to it it also allowed traffic
to move a lot quicker not anymore but
for a long time it probably helped speed
up the growth of the city which they had
to have in order to to have an uptown
they need the uptown not to that's a
place to put the rich but to put the
people who know do the work and they had
to get up in downtown somehow the year
that the subway opened which was 1904
800,000 immigrants arrived in New York
it's like a whole city arriving you know
and they had to make the subway work
to have some place for all those people
to to live that's one year eight hundred
thousand people so but that was 1904 so
that's a hundred years ago yeah and the
FF Train still doesn't get here on time
but look at the C train well I know
you're signing books and there are
people who would love to have you sign
something sure one more question
now if you look at the McDonald Avenue
it's like Coney Island is little
Pakistan to be traffic lights away take
a road in church is little Bangladesh
and I'm so common thinking about the
permanence of change how within eight
years the ethnic composition where they
make the heart of Mary was a solid and
I'd ready to go and speak to have the
people didn't understand what I was
saying
and now this progress that what I'm
saying but at least my English is sort
of a more acceptable because and John
Ferris was our first reformers to get
elected in that area but when he when
there was a heavy Irish district now the
same for me for the sembly district what
constitutes Park Slope Windsor Terrace
and a piece of language is probably more
one of the most Asian districts in
Brooklyn and it shows the prevalence of
the change above them but you know it's
not unique to Brooklyn in Belfast in
Belfast Northern Ireland there's now a
little Manila on the Lower Falls Road
which is the first time in the history
of Northern Ireland since 1680
that anybody moved to you know they
moved out of northern island that now
it's the Royal and what's what's funny
only the whole Filipino colony in these
awful buildings the Catholics abandoned
they're doing exactly the work that they
do when they come here they're working
in hospitals because nobody else will
take the job of emptying the bedpan
drives the newspaper vendors but that's
that's okay when I hear those stories
I'm cheered up am i I went to Barnes &
Noble down here and on 7:37 Devon you
know about six months ago or a year ago
to get one and a guy showed me a local
paper and the headline was his Manhattan
the next Brooklyn Wow when I kept United
says 61 15 years old I was told of Jacob
we're going past third Street don't talk
because it's heavy Irish neighborhood
and we might get beaten up so please
shut up and don't say a word till we get
to Prichard square the world has changed
thank you very much thank you thank you
all for coming thank you people decided
with Pete Hamill is author of downtown
my Manhattan is published by Time Warner
books